pee
how's my girl do you want to know what
my surprise was
we got engaged look at him mom got a
ring
is that
upsetting why are you sad baby
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
got engaged back in october i mean it's
a beautiful thing and thanks to the
famous family's new hulu series the
kardashians fans get an inside look at
the romantic proposal and the moment
court told her kids the big news
penelope was just really crying he's
upset i heard it you have a real insight
into what the girls are doing not only
you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes the
43 year old reality star shares three
kids with her ex scott disick
twelve-year-old mason nine-year-old
penelope and seven-year-old reign and
while helping the blink 182 drummer plan
the beach proposal court's mom kris
jenner made the executive decision not
to invite the kids even though travis's
children 23 year old atiana 18 year old
landon and 16 year old alabama were
going i think it's her decision to break
it to her kids the way she wants and
chris she doubled down on all that
listen for us to have to lie to scott
and get them here under false pretenses
would have been really hard for all of
us
so
you know what this is the right thing to
do and they're all adults
basically so
that's the way i feel about it after
trav popped the question court made a
call to her kids and let's just say p
didn't take the news too well
is that upsetting
why are you sad baby
i feel bad for pete
penelope took it hard i think it's a big
change for her and even though she loves
travis i think she doesn't know what
that means
you know like is that taking me away is
it i think she just doesn't know what it
means and while penelope was in tears
rain
he was here for it mom and travis got
engaged
what does that mean it means he proposed
and gave me a ring not exciting
i do wish that my kids were here i think
it would have made them feel more
included in the decision kind of and
like part of the surprise
i know that my mom
made that decision
and it probably wasn't her best
as for court she likened penelope's
reaction to her own experience when her
mom got remarried in 1991. once my dad
was accepting of bruce it felt like i
could take a deep breath and like be
friendly with bruce and get along with
him and not feel bad i think that it's
really important for scott to like be
accepting of
my of our relationship so that the kids
can feel good
and all that echoes with the push
founder sister chloe told et back in
2019. it took them years but my dad
would come over once a week for family
dinners and would play golf with my
stepdad and so we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be as for court and travis the
two said i do in an unofficial las vegas
ceremony last month but are keeping the
real wedding plans hush-hush you did a
practice run on the wedding
congratulations thank you
so when is the real wedding we don't
know yet we're just you know living our
best lives
[Music]
you